just an open-ended question what are
your thoughts about what's really going
on today between ukraine and russia
what's led up to this
what led up to this was uh
the formation of vladimir putin
the
the
um vladimir putin was a kgb agent in
east germany
in the town of dresden
he was not much of an agent he was
mid-level bureaucrats but
you know when in those days when when
you joined as a soviet citizen you
joined the kgb
you were a flaming communist
and a patriot
okay so and the kgb was what's i mean
that was the elite of the elite right
uh
so he he was a mid-level bureaucrat and
dresden uh had the good life because
east germany uh stand of living was much
higher than
in the soviet union
uh he
there's pictures of him he was pretty
chubby he liked the german beer
and
you can't blame him the german beer is
pretty good i mean yes
there's no bad beer
so anyway uh and then there was a a
moment that uh pretty much uh shaped him
ideologically
um it was when uh in 1989
when the wall came down east german
citizens
went stormed a bunch of uh
stasi
offices
and undressed them they went after the
kgb office
and uh the kgb the guards wouldn't let
them in and they told him
go away or else we're gonna shoot
so they went away they came back the
next day
vladimir called berlin
and
asked berlin do we have permission to
shoot if they come back
and berlin said
we called moscow they are silent
that was the moment when vladimir
understood that uh
gorbachev was letting go of east germany
and this uh you know and the idea that
you know he belonged to the most
powerful organization on the planet and
he was he was fundamentally and has had
no powers to do something
that
was the beginning of vladimir putin who
he is today because he sort of inside
said we gotta we we gotta we gotta fix
this meaning we can't let this happen
because it was seven decades of control
essentially yes we gotta fix this we uh
we we're losing the greatness that we
were and you know and then
not much later the soviet union fell
apart
uh and
this is what vladimir's uh
goal was and still is is reestablishing
the russian empire
and so he's still a patriot mind you i
think he's not a communist anymore maybe
there's some
residual communist thinking but he's a
patriot and he is i believe
a huge narcissist
because you know you put that together
he he thinks he's the only one who can
do what he's trying to do to
you know establish uh the greatness of
russia and build himself a monument
right next to peter the great and and
that is the driving force
behind what's going on in ukraine right
now that's the driving force behind
what's going on ukraine right now okay
uh do you think the worst is here or do
you think it's gonna get uglier
i'm afraid it could get uglier we
there's a very fine line that the the
west
must walk because
he there's speculation that putin is not
entire entirely sane
well there's insanity and there's
insanity what he's doing actually by
invading ukraine is insane by itself you
know if
if a sane person does not go after uh
women and children but there's a
if it goes beyond that when he's
going crazy
scott nukes so we got to be really
really careful you know we can't let him
get away with this
uh but uh
you know
hopefully you know some talks will
happen and hopefully he finds an off
ramp because
if he stays in ukraine he's done
he will not survive this in terms of you
know long-term the ukrainians will not
allow him to occupy the country without
major damage
the uh
the fall of the soviet union started
with the debacle in afghanistan right
and this is going
if if he occupies all of ukraine you're
going to have in afghanistan uh
multiplied several times over do do you
think he
he watched how things were handled in
afghanistan and the taliban got what 80
billion dollars or whatever the
equipment was and the mishandling of it
that was brought up both by the folks on
the left and the right so it wasn't like
a political side they're just
disagreeing do you think he saw that as
an opportunity to say this is the time
for us to invade ukraine
yes
yes
i don't know if it was the deciding
factor but clearly it looked like the
americans the american military doesn't
know what they're doing anymore
it appears that the generals actually
had a different plan and were overridden
by civilians in the white house who
don't know what they're doing so if you
enjoyed this little segment from the
podcast click over here to watch the
entire podcast and if you've not
subscribed to the channel please do so
take care everybody
[Music]